[Música]
i
en irán todavía existe la creencia de
que el acuerdo nuclear puede salvarse a
pesar de las actuaciones que hemos visto
en los últimos días que podrían
demostrar lo contrario por ejemplo la
prohibición de estas visitas relámpago
de los inspectores de la organización
internacional de energía atómica de las
declaraciones del líder supremo de que
irán podría enriquecer uranio al 60 por
ciento mientras jon lo hace al 20 lo que
ya está quebrando el acuerdo nuclear sin
embargo vemos aspectos positivos también
como ese acuerdo que se llegó con la
organización internacional de energía
atómica de esperar tres meses más antes
de tomar medidas más drásticas y es que
se cree que a nivel diplomático se están
llevando negociaciones o por lo menos
conversaciones o aproximaciones que
logren que en un momento dado se pueda
llegar a un acuerdo a pesar de que irán
dice que eeuu tiene que levantar las
sanciones para que esto suceda proceda
de un acuerdo escalonado en el que cada
uno vaya cumpliendo sus compromisos y
que así se logre salvar este acuerdo
i
[Música]
la unión europea tiene la esperanza de
que eeuu e irán
vuelvan a retomar relaciones para
mantener vivo el pacto nuclear uno de
los grandes hitos de la diplomacia en
los últimos años con tal de
revitalizarlo el jefe de la diplomacia
europea josep borrell ha invitado a eeuu
a una reunión informal con iran y el
resto de países signatarios del pacto
aunque aún esta invitación se está
estudiando la unión europea ha advertido
a irán que tiene que dar pasos positivos
para no alejarse del pacto y deje de
enriquecer uranio si aún quiere mantener
viva la vía diplomática la unión europea
hasta ahora siempre ha actuado de
mediadora para mantener vivo el pacto
porque considera que es clave para la
paz en la región y considera que la
única solución es el diálogo
i
recuperar el acuerdo nuclear con irán es
uno de los puntos más importantes en la
agenda internacional de joe biden para
acercarse a iran bailén anunció la
semana pasada que quitara las
restricciones de viaje a diplomáticos de
ese país aceptó volver a diálogos con
iraní existió de la idea de aplicar
todas las sanciones de la onu a teherán
sin embargo eeuu le pide primero a irán
que cumpla completamente con los
acuerdos nucleares antes de remover las
sanciones que fueron impuestas por el
gobierno de donald trump algo que
teherán ya rechazó pidiendo que primero
se quiten las sanciones antes de empezar
a cumplir con estos requisitos del
acuerdo que fue firmado entre irán eeuu
china y los países más grandes de la
unión europea para evitar que el
gobierno iraní logre la construcción de
un arsenal nuclear
[Música]